I'M AN AMAZING PERSON
WITH AN AMAZING LIFE.
- AND I'M LIZ.
I'M A COLLEGE GRADUATE
AND I EXPECT THE BEST.
I'M THE DRIVEN ONE.
- AND I'M TRYING TO HAVE A LIFE.
OUR PR FIRM
IS CALLED PUBLIZITY.
- IT'S BASED OFF OUR NAMES.
SO THIS MORNING,
WE HAVE MEETING WITH, LIKE,
A VERY DEMANDING NEW CLIENT.
THE CEO OF CULTURED YOGURT WATER
AND LIZ BETTER WAKE UP.
YOGURT WATER? I LOVE IT.
- WOW.
I THINK, LIKE, A LOT OF WOMEN
REALLY WANT TO DRINK SOMETHING
THAT'S, LIKE, MEDIUM-THICK.
- TRY IT.
- I'M GONNA TRY IT,
IF YOU DON'T MIND.
LIKE, I LIE IN MEETINGS A LOT,
IT'S TRUE.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF JUST,
LIKE SUCKING DOWN
ONE OF THESE LITTLE THINGS.
BUT, LIKE, IN THIS CASE,
I REALLY DO HATE WATER.
LIKE, I HATE IT.
IT'S, LIKE, VERY EXCITING
TO BE TRYING A NEW BEVERAGE.
[sniffs]
I LOVE IT.
IT'S DELICIOUS.
- WELL, TH--THANK YOU.
- I LIKE WATER,
BUT I WANT THAT SOUR TASTE THAT,
LIKE, ONLY YOGURT CAN BRING.
SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP
PROMOTE YOUR PRODUCT?
UM, LET'S SEE.
[snorts]
OH, I JUST HAD
AN AMAZING IDEA.
WHAT IF WE DID AN EVENT?
- LIZ!
SORRY.
YOU ARE A GENIUS.
- I LOVE YOU.
- I LOVE YOU, TOO.
- YOU'RE MY BEST FRIEND.
- HERE'S WHAT I'M THINKING
WE SHOULD DO.
CULTURED WATER IS, LIKE,
VERY CULTURED,
AND, LIKE, WHAT IS THE
MOST CULTURED THING--
[snorts]
OH, MY GOD. ENGLAND.
- OH, ENGLAND.
- LONDON, ENGLAND.
- OH, MY GOD,
I LOVE LONDON ENGLAND.
- SO IT'S, LIKE,
A THEME PARTY ALL ABOUT
LONDON, ENGLAND
AND CULTURED WATER.
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE,
LIKE, ADELE PERFORM!
WE SHOULD HAVE
ADELE PERFORM!
- I THINK ADELE MIGHT BE
A LITTLE EXPENSIVE.
- MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
I COULD PERFORM THEN.
I COULD DO IT.
I COULD ACTUALLY JUST COMPLETE
THE PERFORMANCE.
I COULD DO IT.
I COULD PERFORM.
- RIGHT?
- BUT--
- YOU DON'T PERFORM.
- MM.
- LIZ IS, LIKE,
CRAZY UNTALENTED,
AND I DON'T KNOW
IF SHE CAN DELIVER.
SO I'M THINKING WHAT IF WE HAD
ANYBODY ELSE PERFORM?
- MM, OR I COULD DO IT.
- OR YOU KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO
IS WE COULD JUST HAVE, LIKE,
A MONKEY WITH DOWN SYNDROME
SMASHING ON CYMBALS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS, LIKE, A GOOD
POSSIBILITY FOR SOMETHING TO DO.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, LIZ,
I'M GONNA STOP YOU RIGHT THERE
BECAUSE I WOULD BE
SO NERVOUS FOR YOU
IF THAT TINY MONKEY
WITH THE BRAIN PROBLEM
WERE TO JUMP UP AND JUST SCRATCH
ON SOMEONE'S FACE.
- IT'S, LIKE,
THE CLIENT'S DECISION.
WHATEVER YOU THINK
IS BEST IS FINE.
SO, LIKE, EITHER
WE DO THE MONKEY
OR SOMETHING ELSE
OR WE HAVE LIZ SING.
- RIGHT, AND, LIKE,
WHATEVER YOU THINK IS FREE.
- WELL WHY DON'T WE TRY IT?
WHY DOESN'T LIZ HAVE A SONG--
- GREAT. AMAZING.
- LET'S TRY IT.
[singing nasally]
- ♪ I WOULD LOVE TO SING
♪ AT YOUR EVENT
- WOW.
- WELL THAT'S PROOF POSITIVE
RIGHT THERE THAT WE SHOULD
THINK OF A BUNCH OF OPTIONS.
COMING UP NEXT ON PUBLIZITY...
WHAT IS SHE DOING?